aliens
so sir reginald hargreaves is one of the
most fascinating characters in comic
book history
little is known about the man who goes
by the moniker the monocle
but throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that we've
managed together
about the mysterious figure this
includes his origins
history and our theories on where things
could be going in the future
obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the second season
yet then i highly recommend that you
turn off now
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
i'm your host definition now let's get
into our breakdown of sir reginald
hargreaves
okay so on the surface hargreaves seemed
like an eccentric billionaire that
specialized in a number of things
the character was a famous scientist
inventor
nobel prize-winning olympic gold
medalist that was also
an expert in the advancement of
chimpanzees
get you a man that can do everything now
hargreaves are master fortune by
purchasing a business that specialized
in producing umbrellas all the way back
in 1928
and this funded his endeavors over the
years reginald was a philanthropist
that wished to save the world and he did
this by adopting seven children
all blessed with superpowers the
character trained them at his home
eventually forming the umbrella academy
and together they
stopped several supervillains around the
planet hog reeves was incredibly cruel
to them
and instead of giving them names he gave
them numbers
these numbers were assigned to them in
order of how powerful they were
however as time went on it actually
became more and more clear that this was
actually their level of obedience to him
if anything the power order was the
opposite
with number one aka luther being the
least powerful
and number seven aka vonye being the
most
they were met with worldwide acclaim but
over the years they slowly started to
turn against him
due to the cruelty that he carried when
caring for them and because of this
he seemingly died alone however things
go far deeper with the character
and throughout the show and comic book
series we learn that hargreaves is
actually an
alien now very little is told to us in
the show about where the character comes
from
or what drove him to our planet in the
comics
the information is just as ambiguous
however we do know that his home was
devastated by nuclear war
in the 10th episode of season 1 we catch
a brief glimpse of the character on his
homeworld
as he says farewell to his dying lover
it's clear that he wants to stay
but she realizes that the world needs
him and thus he departs
taking her white violin with him this is
a gift that he would later give devonia
and though there's little told to us in
this moment i think it carries a lot of
weight with it
hargreaves was clearly shocked to the
core by the war that had torn his
homeworld apart
and i believe that he vowed to not allow
this fate to befall another planet
thus he traveled to oz and began to mold
history in a way that would avert the
apocalypse and save us from ourselves
hargreaves travelled across the vastness
of space with his body god abhijat
on board his private vessel the minerva
now the name of this
actually comes from the roman goddess
minerva who is known for her wisdom
and sponsoring of the arts this is of
course something that hargreaves himself
would take up
and thus him coming across space in this
symbolizes the character bringing wisdom
and advancements to our planet as
mentioned earlier
hargreaves purchased an umbrella
business in 1928
and from here he built his fortune we
learned in the 1950s and 60s that the
character began to contribute to our
space divisions
and his advancements led to humanity
developing several new technologies
with a scientist known as grace he
started to experiment
on a monkey called pogo and this
advanced the simeon
far beyond the usual capabilities of
chimpanzees
hargreaves started a relationship with
grace and she began to care for him
and pogo greatly though unintentional
together their work started the space
race to the moon between
america and russia and this eventually
led to the cold war
it seemed that no matter what once a
civilization became advanced enough
they would inevitably descend into war
and thus he started to work with shadowy
organizations to control things from
behind the scenes
reginald wished to gain access to the
dark side of the moon
and thus he needed those that could help
him it's during this time
that he joined the majestic 12. now
grace discovered this and broke off
their relationship
and hulk greaves would later build an
android in her image to take care of him
and his family
we'll talk about this in just a bit but
first i want to focus on the majestic
12.
in case you don't know the majestic 12
is actually a group that are rumored to
exist in our own world
and for decades there have been
conspiracy theories surrounding the
mysterious members that make it up
the majestic 12 is rumored to be a
committee of high-ranking scientists
military leaders and government
officials that control world events
and also hide the existence of ufos the
group was apparently formed all the way
back in 1947
under the orders of president truman and
after recovering an alien spacecraft
they began to cover up the truth from
humanity with them hargreaves started to
work on certain technological
advancements
however he cut ties with them after
realizing they were complicit in the
assassination of jfk
the group threatened to reveal his
identity unless he kept giving them tech
and thus he was forced to kill them
after this point
the group faded into myth and legend and
were not heard from again
hog greaves kept his head down living
with pogo until 1989
it's at this point he emerged once more
after learning that 43 women had
mysteriously given birth to children
after showing no signs of pregnancy
though hargreaves tried to adopt all of
them
he was only able to procure seven and
these became known
as the umbrella academy although this is
never confirmed
it is possible that hargreaves was
actually the cause behind the
pregnancies
and that due to his experiments on
simians he was able to manufacture
children with great gifts this has never
been confirmed
but it's just a theory i've had since we
found out that he was an
alien in the comic books and obviously
let me know if you
agree or disagree with me anyway
hargreaves wish to use the group to
avert the apocalypse
but due to his treatment of them they
left the academy all except for luther
who carried out a mission to the moon
though this eventually turned out to be
pretty pointless
now hargreaves committed suicide hoping
that the children would reunite to stop
armageddon
but they ended up causing it and in a
last-ditch attempt to right their wrongs
they traveled back to the 60s we see
that in this alternate timeline
the group track him down and he actually
manages to go head-to-head with diego
it's at this point that i want to talk
about his powers and how they operate
as there's a lot of grey areas
surrounding them so as you can guess
a guy that's alive from 1928 and
seemingly doesn't age
must be using either the best
anti-wrinkle cream in the world
or he's immortal he might have a ponchon
for some oil of olay
but reginald is actually the latter he
does not age
or at least appear to this may be
because of time on our world working
differently to his
but in the span of a century he barely
changes at all
he's also a master at combat and due to
his abilities in athletics he's a very
skilled acrobat
reginald also possesses a genius level
iq
and because of this he's created a
wealth of technology and serums that
improve animals and humanity when
applied
har greaves is a master assassin and
possesses an expertise in long-range
weapons as well as hand-to-hand ones
this makes him deadly in every scenario
but he only ever kills if he believes it
to be for the good of mankind
so yeah basically the guys in alien
einstein
mixed with batman batman from the movies
you know the one
the the one that doesn't mind killing
people now in the alternate timeline
he met with the umbrella academy but due
to thinking that they were all screw-ups
he decided not to adopt them in the
future
this caused the sparrow academy to be
formed and as reginald had not met
ben he still adopted him and in this
timeline the character did not kill
himself
due to the new academy never leaving him
now it's clear that he's taken a step
back
and that ben is now the leader whether
intentional or not
i'm hoping that this shows things have
changed
in the original timeline he treated all
of the members terribly
except for probably luther who he only
saw is useful
because he obeyed him so much hargreaves
mentally tortured vania
making her believe that she was nothing
because he feared her power
in the case of ben he found his
abilities disgusting
but it appears here that ben has used
this to his advantage
now we don't know that for definite but
we will of course find out more in
season three
now as for the dark side of the moon and
what's up there it is possible that
there's an interdimensional portal
and this does tie in with the comics the
third volume titled hotel oblivion
centers around an interdimensional
prison which reggie uses to trap
supervillains in
it is possible that he's attempting to
get to the moon to learn of this
and i think that in the third season it
will be revealed that he's already
achieved his goal
and that the prison is currently set up
there in this alternate timeline
when it comes to the character you never
really know what you're gonna get
but that's pretty much the basis of who
he is and his history
he will likely forever remain a mystery
but that's what keeps him so fascinating
in my opinion
i think the academy themselves probably
know as much as we do
about the mysterious figure and who
knows if we'll ever fully find out the
truth about him
or where he comes from now i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts on hargreaves
and if you agree with my theories or
have any of your own
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you want something else to
watch after this then check out our
breakdown of the sparrow academy which
is going to be linked at the end
we go over the main characters and also
give our thoughts on what that
a crazy looking box could be now don't
forget that every month on the 15th we
give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
box set is leave a like and subscribe
with notifications on
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat just on a discord
server linked in the description
or a heavy spoilers on twitter anyway
thank you for making it until the end of
the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you